bonsoir jantes et les bateaux c'est
d'être avec nous alors tout d'abord que
représente cette élection d'un président
kanak pour la nouvelle calédonie c'est
historique c'est vrai ce n'était pas
arrivé depuis l'accord de nouméa et
l'institution du gouvernement collégial
en 1998 il ya déjà eu un chef du
gouvernement calédonien face était le
conseil de gouvernement calédonien
c'était en entre 1982 et 1984 et c'était
justement jean marie tjibaou qui a
profité d'une d'un désaccord entre les
deux groupes loyalistes pour accéder
dans que alors à l'époque c'était la
vice-présidence du conseil du
gouvernement parce que le président
s'était le commissaire et c'était
surtout un rôle symbolique lui était
vraiment le chef de l'exécutif us
à l'époque on sait qu'il ya un grand
débat dans en nouvelle calédonie
évidemment sur cette question
d'indépendance comment cette élection
est perçu par la population
vous voulez parler du référendum par la
pop
oui oui alors basse et c'est quelque
chose que que les calédoniens attend
depuis longtemps ils ont vécu dix ans
grandit certains ont grandi avec ça donc
ils savent ils connaissent tous les
connaissent tous les enjeux ils savent
ils savent exactement ce ce que ça
représente en tout cas pour coup leur
archipel est il n'y a qu'à voir les taux
de participation qui sont des taux de
participation qui frôle je crois qu'au
dernier au dernier référendum on a frôlé
les 90 % de taux de toute participation
c'est dire l'importance que représente
cet enjeu électoral 40 cas cette
victoire est due à la relative
unification des forces d'intervention
qui a été réalisé par part loué ma peau
alors oui c'est vrai que l'accord entre
les deux les deux grands groupes
indépendantistes a mis du temps à
déboucher les deux grands groupes sont
indépendantes y sont restés compter
pendant 5 moins sûr sur leur sur leurs
positions donc ils ont mis ils ont mis
du temps à lens est vrai que louis mapou
avait une personnalité plus consensuel
samu une épée ou n'était pas forcément
apprécié par l'ensemble des électorale
indépendantiste et puis il ya eu il est
cet accord donc qui va déboucher sur sur
la présidence du congrès à la fin du
mois de juillet c'est c'est un partage
des pouvoirs entre les deux grands
groupes politiques bon dentiste pardon
maintenant on va voir si en face les non
indépendantistes vont réussir à prendre
le congrès et court-circuité cet accord
indépendantiste alors c'est un signe
positif tout de même assez fort à
quelques mois du référendum et pourtant
l'opinion reste majoritairement contre
l'indépendance qu'est-ce que ça laisse
présager selon vous alors je honnêtement
je saurai pas je ne saurais pas dire
enfin faire des prévisions sur sur ce
que ce que ça pourrait donner dans tous
les cas là les indépendantistes y joue
un il joue un défi majeur avant ce
troisième référendum c'est de prouver
qu'il que leur projet que le projet
indépendantiste est un projet viable et
et qui peut et qui peut tout à fait que
et que les calédoniens peuvent tout à
fait voter oui à l'indépendance sans
avoir de crainte donc il sent dans un
moment où il va relever un défi prendre
un risque surtout prendre un risque
parce que c'est aussi un risque de
perdre de perdre de l'électorat et
finalement de rater un peu l'exécutif
quel univers en tout cas l'om un point
évoqué après son agression vouloir
s'attaquer à des
dossiers très importants comme la
réouverture inde et des frontières et
des crises et des finances publiques
dernière petite question quel est l'état
de l'archipel après plus d'un an de
crise sanitaire
alors je pense qu'il faut remonter un
peu plus loin pour connaître un peu
l'état de l'archipel à 2018 avec le
premier référendum d'autodétermination
je pense que s'il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes qui s'est installé depuis
depuis 2018 incertitudes économiques que
l'incertitude politique incertitudes
sociale et c'est vraiment ajouter à cela
l'épidémie enfin la prendre et me c'est
moi un climat d'incertitude il ya eu le
dossier de lusine vallée qui a pu être
être au final il ya un accord là dessus
donc ça a pu être réglé il ya et ensuite
il ya eu ce ce gouvernement qui n'est
pas encore gisent n'avait pas jusqu'ici
entrée en exercice et qui est revenu
encore ajouté de l'incertitude on s'est
vraiment un climat je pense
d'incertitude sur place
merci beaucoup photo je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste 1 pour le média
outre-mer 360° de merci à vous